so I've been home alone for a week and I
haven't done jack [ __ ] as in I haven't
really done anything in rolla kousaka 3
was which was very underwhelming I was
kind of planning to do all of these
upping things but nothing really
happened and I was I was busy with
school and it really wasn't so amazing
of a week but i did that live stream
though so that was pretty cool but
anyway I finally opened this bike up
again yesterday which was after that
week of pretty much doing nothing which
was quite quite a shame and I loaded the
park without actually knowing what I
would do and then I saw that flat ride
and it was kind of unfinished and I kind
of wanted to do something with that I
this is not going to be the final
theming of course I still want to add
some buildings and other stuff but I
really didn't want to leave that thing
bear as that is pretty much the worst
thing to actually look at I wanted to I
wanted to be somewhat somewhat finished
at least and then there's the other
thing which is the fact that i really
need to work on that new area with flat
rides which is also something that i'm
going to do in this episode and which
was something that I wanted to do in the
first place when it opened this Pike but
then i remembered that like for us the
thousandth time in a row i forgot to
download CFR's so that was amazing and
it that that's kind of keeping me from
while progressing in this park I guess
it's just a fact that i keep forgetting
to get new flat rides and what i do i
messed them up so bad that had actually
crashes my game so oh my god I'm great
at that and that's why I decided to do
some random foliage work and I don't
know I just love doing this I just love
placing those rocks and just general
nonsense all over them I know it's not
realistic and I know it's over the top
and and for some reason I normally don't
do this I normally go for more realistic
approaches and stuff like that but I've
been working on this bike for so long
and doing all that over-the-top stuff
that it's nearly becoming my style and I
do want to not well get it that far
because I definitely don't want to make
it my style to go over the top all the
time but I would like to do that with my
next park because I don't know what I'm
going to do with the next park I
at some point I figured that I would
turn my let's play series into a random
let's play series with as in uploading
random videos of just random things in
rolla cosec and three every time so it
wouldn't be just one park for the let's
play but actually multiple power
exchanges whatever I happen to work on
in roller coaster in three and one of
the reasons why I decided to do that and
yeah that was quite some terrible
checkerboard well stuff over there
because I totally forgot what the
combination was but basically what I
kind of wanted to do with that I forgot
what I was going to say mm-hmm oh wait
wait I remember yeah so what I wanted to
do is is just to upload random things so
i would actually upload everything I do
in roller coaster can three because
right now it seems as if doing this
let's play park it's the only thing that
I do in the game but there are many
other things that I don't record and I
almost feel as if it's kind of a shame
that I don't record those things and
it's a waste of what could have been
some awesome timelapses and some awesome
let's play videos but I do think it
would be better to just keep my let's
play well of one park and then do random
timelapses whatever i'll call that
series like random rollerCoaster Tycoon
3 shenanigans with silver at which i do
all the other things in roller coaster
three I don't know if that's a good idea
but I'm like I might give it a shot
really just to get everything out there
that i'm working on just two well I
suppose get videos of the things that
I'm not making videos off currently but
also do kind of show of what I'm working
on and prove that this is not the only
thing that I work on because sometimes I
really I'm like in the middle of a
project in roller coasting to three and
then it almost feels like a chore to
come back to this let's play park
because you know sometimes you don't
want to have multiple projects at the
same time but yeah that's that's pretty
much my situation at this point so i
might make some other videos but that's
only as soon as I finish this park
because I don't want to get too messy
when it comes to my channel and I'm
already kind of at that stage where I
probably make too many videos because
it's not that I play the game more it's
just that I record more random stuff and
then as that's
rollerCoaster Tycoon one let's play and
it almost feels a bit too messy to me I
don't know I just like to have my
general neat and organized and just one
one subject I don't know if it's a great
idea to have all that stuff going on but
I suppose so it's also a nice idea
because I keep having ideas for new
series that I never really do but I
could just put all of those things in a
new random rollick Oh second three
shenanigans series so definitely want to
give that a try and what else can i say
i suppose i could go on topic and
actually talk about when i'm currently
doing here but it's a very simple kind
of thing that i've done all over the
park actually it's just that combination
of weber's rocks because they are
absolutely phenomenal they've they've
got the best lectures easily these are
the types of rocks set you would almost
see in other games or at least I imagine
them sometimes these are the types of
rocks that you could build Skyrim
landscapes with and stuff like that and
that's why I decided to mix them with
this random foliage and get some magical
ish foliage out there because no real
park of course would have rocks like
this I don't really think about that too
often but sometimes I do feel that rock
work is something that's very overused
in roller coaster can three as it not
that I'm tired of seeing it but I feel
like it's used in roller coaster going 3
much more than it is in real life in
real life you don't have too much rock
work unless you're on a mountain of
course but who built a roller coaster of
mountains and I feel like every single
spot that's bear and you will have
something in every single spot of course
it's going to be covered with the rock
works by many people and I'm very guilty
of doing that as well and I like to come
up with excuses like yeah the spot is
just meant to be over the top but then
again that's partially an excuse to well
make things that make no sense I suppose
it's fun in that sense and at this point
I was like okay I'm gonna have a I'm
gonna have to have another building of
it because I kind of want to fill this
area with the flat rides with random
buildings but I haven't really decided
in a certain style so I just decided to
go for it a train
them and just build something and
there's still now to be an Alpine ish
kind of thing like in the rest of the
pike but I'm still doubting whether i
should actually do that and i might
possibly mix in some other themes don't
quite know what but i'm actually
thinking about adding some classical
influences because classical is always
amazing i just love it just the temples
and pillows and all that good stuff it's
amazing and i haven't really used any of
that in this point of course we've
really i got the pillows of like these
orgies things but that's not an entire
entirely classical not in a sense that
for example Ralphie's SAT is so I might
want to see if I can mix that in
somewhere somehow don't quite know but
before I do that I should still get some
more CFR's and that's something that
I've been struggling with for years it's
not even that hard to get CFO's but I
always forget about it I think at some
point I used to have like 800 because
some scenery sets on my old computer and
like ten CFR's and plenty of ctrs to its
really I don't know why but I just suck
at finding CFR's or something even
though they're all custom scenery depot
it's just something that I really not
it's the part of the problem is actually
that I didn't pay too much attention to
it very very long time and now I'm stuck
with barely any CFR's but still barely
any experience of where to get them and
how to work with them so that's
definitely something I should try and
well I'm at that I should probably get
all of imagine a John sea of ice because
I am kind of familiar with those and at
this point this is kind of when I meant
with the classical style by the way with
zero geez things because he has those
little pillows but also those things on
the sides in it it almost looked like a
Corinthian temple ish kind of thing so I
like that but I don't really know what
else to do with this little row of
houses the plan is is going to be a
small row of houses that's kind of a
kind of blocked the view from the roller
coaster to the flat rides area because
of course there should be a distinction
between the two themes over there and I
don't know I just don't want the roller
coaster riders to see all those flat
rides over there
I kind of an hour have this thing as a
little border in between two areas and
when it comes to those flat rides I
might just have some flat rides that are
incorporated into buildings that stuff
like that not going to add a restaurant
I was planning to add a restaurant over
there but then I saw that I also had a
restaurant at the entrance so I'm not
going to do that and I'm just gonna work
on that next episode and hopefully I'll
be able to pick up some nice CFR's so
see you then